trois cent mille euros c'est le montant
du budget trappistes en basket cette
saison soit l'un des plus petits de
nationale 2 quand la moyenne tourne
autour de 400 mille euros sur la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines trouver des
sponsors s'avère compliqué je sais bien
évidemment pas suffisant si on quand on
a des ambitions il faut maintenant tout
ne se fait pas qu'avec l'argent mais là
on est vraiment pour le coup un petit
peu limité il manque quelques quelques
partenaires qui nous permettrait aussi
de pérenniser pérenniser la vie du club
et puis d'avoir des objectifs ambitieux
parce que l'on doit avoir des entretiens
ambitieux sur trappe et les 50 en dix
minutes avant la rencontre de
championnat deux partenaires historiques
du club ont renouvelé leur confiance à
le sct la société est ce simeoni a
prolongé son partenariat pour la dixième
année et yprema fait de ses onze années
de mariage présent nationale 2 depuis
cinq saisons le club vise la montée en
nationale une à l'horizon 2014 voire en
pro b en 2016
mais pour cela il faudra trouver deux
cent mille euros de nouveaux
partenariats sont à l'étude en attendant
le club doit faire avec les moyens du
bord et s'est offert pour l'occasion la
présence d'un ministre c'est la crise
qu'ils ont entreprises n'ont pas non
plus démarches telles qu'elles peuvent
distribuer ainsi et d'échecs d'où
l'importance du projet et que les
entreprises soient convaincus que
derrière
le projet il ya aussi en associant le
nom de leur marque à 7 à ce club la
possibilité de renforcer leur propre
entre activités mais aussi
l'attractivité du territoire
ce projet le scp est en train de le
construire le club trappistes s'oriente
sur la formation en s'ouvrant aux autres
villes de la communauté d'agglomération
comme la verrière où montigny le
bretonneux
et quoi de mieux pour lancer ces
signatures qu'une victoire sur son
parquet face à calais 64 à 60 3